[Music]
all right folks so before we say good
night I would like to take a moment and
thank all of the generous sponsors who
make our show possible tonight's episode
of the Pete home show was brought to you
by your mom signing her name at the end
of all of her text
messages just in case you don't have
your mom's number in your phone and just
in case you thought it was a stranger
texting you don't forget your father's
birthday thanks your mom signing her
name at the end of all our text messages
the pet home show is also brought to you
by your friend's baby who you're pretty
sure is inherently
evil sure he's giggling and laughing
while he bashes his teddy bear's head in
with a wooden block but that's just not
something babies do it's fed up you know
it the baby knows it and somewhere deep
down his weird parents know it too
thanks evil
[Applause]
[Music]
baby